this podcast episode is brought to you
by helix sleep
sleep is super important to me in the
last few years i've come to conclude it
is the end-all be-all
that all good things good mood good
performance good everything
seem to stem from good sleep so i've
tried a lot
to optimize and i've tried pills and
potions
all sorts of different mattresses you
name it and for the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the
number one best overall mattress pick of
2020 by gq magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk free they'll even pick
it up from you if you don't love it and
now my dear listeners helix is offering
up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim these are not
cheap pillows either so getting two for
free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off
and two free pillows at helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to 200
off so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x sleep dot com slash
tim
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than ten years
ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase
many of us are deficient in vitamin d i
found that true
for myself which is usually produced in
our bodies from sun exposure so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com tim
you'll receive up to a year's supply of
vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your subscription
again that's athleticgreens.com
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
greetings friends this is a rare preface
to
the intro so there is a separate intro
but after recording this episode
which i was very happy with i wanted to
add a number of additional notes
first ifs is an incredible system
and it really goes far beyond any type
of trauma so it applies to
i would say each and every one of us it
will help you work with your inner
critic
it will help you to befriend inner
voices not in the pathological sense
and at one point in this episode i do a
live demo as the patient with richard
of ifs so that is a real life
real subject matter demo and be patient
this is a dense episode at points and
you may find
yourself wondering what the hell are
these two talking about be patient just
sit with it for a minute or two
and it'll get back to terra firma and
you will have your bearings
and you can think of ifs also which has
been very helpful to me personally
and i've seen some incredible i mean i
would say almost miraculous before and
afters
in video of therapeutic sessions
can be compared to perhaps gtd getting
things done so getting things done by
david allen incredible system david's
been on the podcast
is excellent for getting rid of all the
stuff
right the work death by a thousand paper
cuts
and open loops and things floating
around different systems things that
aren't captured getting all that
stuff which a lot of people would think
of in a work capacity into some kind of
flow and system so you can work with it
and
give yourself some peace of mind imagine
if you could do that if you had a system
for doing that for your emotions for
the flare-ups of energy
of anger of sadness of self-flagellation
if you had some kind of system that
allowed you to contend with all of that
stuff ifs is one such system and also
this episode is the first time that i
talk openly and i did not plan on this
about everything that has happened since
i published
my episode on childhood abuse so there
you have the preface to the intro
and now to the intro but before i get
there
i can't help but read one quote which
applies to all of this episode
it's a quote from jack cornfield if your
compassion does not include yourself
it is incomplete and with that to the
intro we go
hello boys and girls this is tim ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show
my guest today i've wanted to have on
for years now
richard schwartz he began his career as
a family therapist and an academic at
the university of illinois
at chicago he is now on the faculty of
the department of psychiatry at harvard
medical school
but it was at the university of illinois
at chicago
where he discovered that family therapy
alone did not achieve full symptom
relief and in asking patients why he
learned that they were plagued by what
they called
parts and we'll get into what that means
these patients became his teachers as
they described how their parts formed
networks of inner relationships that
resembled the families he had been
working with
he also found that as they focused on
and thereby separated from their parts
they could shift into a state
characterized by qualities like
curiosity
calm confidence and compassion he called
that inner essence
the self and was amazed to find it even
in severely diagnosed and traumatized
patients
from these explorations the internal
family systems otherwise known as ifs
model was born in the early 1980s ifs is
now evidence-based
and has become a widely used form of
psychotherapy particularly with trauma
it provides a non-pathologizing
optimistic and empowering perspective
and a practical and effective set of
techniques for working with individuals
couples families and more recently
corporations and classrooms and i want
to add just
a little bit more context which richard
mayer may not disabuse me of but
one way to think about this is as a tool
kit
for reconciling parts of yourself
that may have conflict
amongst them or difficulties amongst
them parts of yourself that you've
disavowed and therefore it is not
limited to
heavily traumatized patients in a
psychotherapeutic context so
what we're going to be talking about in
this episode i think applies
to just about everyone i'm going to
hedge by not saying everyone although i
if i'm being honest thank everyone in
many many many different contexts so
with
all of that preamble said richard
welcome to the show thank you tim
i'm honored by those words and also uh
just so
excited to be with you i've been a fan
and
particularly a fan of the session you
did several
ago where you were so disclosive about
your own history
just thought that was amazingly
courageous and
a service to all to everybody appreciate
you saying that
and it's it's been one hell of a journey
both since the podcast and leading up to
it i was wondering what what it's been
like and what uh
kind of feedback you've gotten well
let's let's talk about it i haven't
spoken publicly about the
after effects or the consequences
positive
and unintended i will say that
for those people who don't know what
we're referring to i put out an episode
of this podcast in september you can
find it at dot blog forward slash trauma
which disclosed history of
sexual abuse so suffering at the hands
of an abuser from
ages two to four at a babysitter's house
and
talked about my healing journey
subsequent to that
my ups and downs my battles with
depression and
all sorts of other things in
conversation with
a close friend of mine debbie millman
who also
is a survivor of sexual abuse although
we both take some issue with that word
survivor but nonetheless
putting that aside that was the episode
and
i expected since it was
in some respects many years in the
making i anticipated
putting it into book form after my
parents passed away so it was always
inside my head 15 or 20 years in the
future something i would do
and as soon as it was published
my response to it on some level
was that of feeling like i was in a
surreal alternate reality because
it was now current tense or in some
sense
past tense right i published this thing
that i thought wasn't going to ever see
the light of day or be shared with the
public for
15 to 20 years and it was bizarre
i had girded myself for
a tsunami of emotions and difficulty and
maybe attacks and so on i
set rules with my team and policies
that i could stay entirely off of social
media we turned off comments on certain
types of posts
really to stem the flow and the first
two days i'd cleared my entire calendar
for that week
to have space first two days were very
tranquil
and i don't know if that's because i was
genuinely at peace if there was some
type of
shock i couldn't tell you i don't claim
to have that level of self-awareness but
it was very very calm and then having so
much
space for the rest of the week was very
challenging i typically
run pretty hot in the sense that i like
traveling in sixth gear and doing a lot
so having that much time to
ruminate or to experience
consciousness uncluttered by activity
in retrospect maybe was a little harder
on me
than filling my calendar if you can
imagine that
i remember having rabbi jonathan sacks
on the podcast and he said you know
to avoid depression after certain points
he just made his calendar very busy and
he said he would recommend it to anyone
and i did the opposite and it was
very challenging so i had a lot of just
as an example
and i haven't spoken anybody publicly
but here we are and i'm pretty well
caffeinated so i'll try to cut
short my uh my monologue here in a
second
but i had a lot of
anger and rage come up but the
the way in which it came up was very
surprising to me
i had this flood i remember it was on
the wednesday
after this podcast came out on monday
this flood of memories of past slights
many of them really trivial
it just seemed like emails i didn't like
or rejections that hurt my feelings or
fill in the blank and i was so pissed
off all day on wednesday and
i didn't try to fix it i didn't
worry about it but i i thought it was
really quite
surprising that this anger was coming to
the surface but it wasn't specific to
any of the abuse
it was in just dozens of kind of
trite or in inconsequential slights
from my past and i was just pissed off
all day long and
then when the podcast
really hit escape velocity in the sense
that it was
widely shared enough that a lot of my
friends had heard it
that's when things got a little harder
because i would say of my
very close male friends
and i don't have that many close friends
by design
let's just arbitrarily say 20. i would
say seven or eight of them
reached out to me to confess that they
had been sexually abused and never told
anyone
wow and some of them sent me voice memos
really kind of tear jerking
heart shredding audio and i mean just
thinking about it i'm like
welling up with tears a bit because it
was [ __ ] emotionally
difficult for them and also very
challenging for me to
act as a sort of recipient or
support and i'm glad they reached out
i'm really
glad they reached out i expected there
would be a lot of this so we received
tons of emails tons of blog comments
tons of
handwritten letters from people
describing their experiences
but that was really very difficult and
to wrap up
since this is interview intended to ask
you questions
i'm very very very proud of it
and i'm not proud often that's something
i
have always had difficulty with but i
don't accept
praise well or let it land well
i'm really proud of it and it did a lot
of good and
it was it was tough but not in the ways
that i had anticipated
yeah well i'm so glad you can be proud
of it because uh
i agree i think it it really served us
to have some of your stature be that
open about it and
uh yeah and live to see the light of day
like you said
let's talk more about living to see the
light of day because
you have worked in many places with many
people
and some of those people perhaps have
resigned
to a life of darkness
or a life that is shadowed
by certain experiences trauma depression
suicidal ideation etc could you and i
don't know if this name is going to ring
a bell because i'm not sure if you
anonymized it or somebody else did
but there's a great piece and medium
inside the revolutionary treatment that
could
change psychotherapy forever and in it i
read
about the story of roxanne
and how that was part of developing
ifs could you share that story please
this was in the early 1980s and i was
a fresh graduate of a phd program in
maryland family therapy
and i was trying to prove that family
therapy
was the thing was found the holy grail
and so i did an outcome study
with a bunch of bulimic clients which
was a syndrome that was new on the scene
at the time
and she was one of them and as i was
trying to do this family therapy with
all these clients and
and succeeded and actually reorganizing
the families
the way the book said to they kept
binging and purging
they didn't realize they'd been cured
and so out of frustration i began asking
why and they started talking
this language of parts which was sort of
bizarre to me i thought
maybe they were sicker than i thought
because they were talking about these
what they called parts of them that
could take over and make them do things
they didn't want to do and and had a lot
of autonomy inside and
and they were talking about them as if
they were sort of full range
personalities
and so i after i got over my
fear about it i got curious and i
started to try and
get my clients to relate differently so
they would say something like
something bad happens in my life and
this critic attacks me inside calls me
all kinds of brutal names
and that brings up another part of me
that feels totally worthless
and alone and empty and desperate
and that feeling is so dreadful that to
the rescue comes the binge to take me
away from all that
but that brings back the critics so so
i'm hearing about these interactions
among
different seeming to be entities inside
of them
and as a family therapist that was
intriguing because that's
what i studied these interactions among
family members
and i began to explore trying to change
some of this
but i was assuming that these parts were
what they seem to be
which is what the field sort of still
assumes
that the critic is just a critical
parental voice
that they internalized and the binge is
an out of control impulse
and so from that frame of understanding
it you're limited what you can
have your clients do so i was getting my
clients to stand up to the critic
and don't take it and control the binge
and they were getting worse but i didn't
know what else to do
when i didn't have i was like the man in
a hole with a shovel you know you just
dig deeper
so until this client who
in addition to being eating disorder
also cut herself
on her wrists and i knew had a bit of a
sex abuse history i didn't know the
extent of it
and so i began to try and work with that
cutting part
in the way i had with these others and
so i would get her
to have a dialogue with it in which she
would try to tell it it couldn't do this
to her anymore
you know that was done no more of this
and i was sort of saying that to the
part too and after a couple hours of
badgering it that way
and finally in her head agreed to not
cut her that week
and then i opened the door the next
session and she has a big gash down the
side of her face
and i just collapsed emotionally inside
when i saw that and i
spontaneously said i give up i can't
beat you with this
and she said the part said
i don't really want to beat you and that
was a turning point because i
shifted out of that controlling coercive
place
to just being curious and i said
so why do you do this to her and i had
her ass that
and the part said sort of told the story
of how
when she was being sexually abused it
had to get her out of her body
and contain the rage that would get her
more abuse
and i shifted again now i don't see it
as
just uh you know i had appreciation for
it but it was like a hero in her life
it really saved her during those abuse
scenes
and as i listened to it more it sounded
like it was still living back in that
time
like it still thought she was five years
old and it still had to protect her in
this way
and that it carried these extreme
beliefs and emotions that we call
burdens
about the world about her about how
dangerous everything was
that drove it these extreme beliefs and
emotions
were like a virus it seemed that like
the coronavirus that drove the way it
operated
and so as i got all that i started to
think
maybe these parts aren't what they see
maybe they are like kids in a family
a dysfunctional family where they're
forced out of their naturally valuable
states to be in roles
to protect the family or because of the
dynamics of the family
that that aren't who they are and don't
serve them but they think are necessary
and in exploring that turns out that's
true
that first of all we all have these
things on calling parts that they called
parts
that from my point of view aren't the
product of trauma
which has been the way it's been viewed
you know multiple personality disorders
the unitary brain got shattered by the
trauma well
for me it's the natural state of the
mind to be
multiple to be to have these parts and
they're all valuable
we wouldn't be born with anything that
wasn't valuable and they come
into our life from birth with us
and then trauma and attachment injuries
and things like that
force them out of their naturally
valuable states
into roles that they don't like but they
think are absolutely necessary to keep
us safe
and then can become symptoms and
problems
but they also if they are listened to
and actually loved ultimately by our
clients
ourselves will transform
so anyway i got rolling on this but
well that's why we have a long forum
podcast we can get rolling
and i just want to say for people who
are
trying to envision what this might look
like and you and i will
will attempt to do a live demo of this
using me as a guinea pig a bit later in
this conversation but
i recall the first time that i saw ifs
in action and i will say that the
and i'm sure you've heard this before
but the the internal family systems
brand name so to speak initially
led me to have a bit of a knee-jerk a
version because i assumed that i would
have to
i i took it very literally i assumed
although i didn't read the internal i
wasn't quite sure what that referred to
that i would have to sit down with my
mom and my dad and my brother and do
family therapy of some type and i was
like i'm out i don't want to do it
but but when i saw ifs in action
for the first time it was when i was
going through the
maps mdma assisted psychotherapy
training program as an auditor i'm not
in any way
licensed as a psychotherapist or
psychologist or otherwise
but as an auditor i wanted to experience
the program and
was able to see session footage of
people with severe ptsd of
post-traumatic stress disorder
in many cases vets who certainly with
the
amplification and assistance of mdma but
nonetheless
in the in this particular case under the
care of michael and annie mithoffer
going through ifs to see where someone
could
start with their say relationship or
thoughts
perspective on rage and where they would
end up
was truly mind-blowing i mean to watch
it in video
form was so impactful uh
and i want to highlight one aspect of
that
that really struck a chord with me
on a whole lot of levels and i'm going
to do this by referring back to this
medium piece and i'll link to this
medium piece in the show notes for
people at tim.blog
podcast if you want to read this as well
but i'm going to read a paragraph
and then i'm going to dive into one
particular aspect of it
so here we go frank anderson a former
clinical instructor at harvard medical
school
was working as a staff psychiatrist at
bessel vander culk's renowned
trauma center in brookline massachusetts
when he first encountered schwartz and
ifs for people who don't know the name
vessel vanderkolk he's the author of a
book
called the body keeps the score which is
a bit of a classic in in this world all
right so back to frank anderson
first encountered schwartz knife s it
flipped his world upside down
quote i had been working with severe
trauma for a long time at the trauma
center and i was one of the many people
who go oh wow anderson recalls within
the mental health world
it's a huge paradigm shift ifs is very
non-pathologizing
every part every symptom has a positive
intention
that kind of blows therapists away what
do you mean shooting heroin has a
positive intention
what do you mean cutting yourself or
binging has a positive intention
end quote so the non-pathologizing
nature
of ifs is is what i want to hone in on
because
you very often hear and this is speaking
as a lay person
if you start kind of wading through the
books
and literature and even in person
conversations in psychiatry you very
often hear the term
maladaptive right this behavior is
maladaptive what this person's doing is
maladaptive meaning it's some kind of
like perversion of an
adaptation that doesn't fit
uh at least the way that i hear it you
could correct me if i'm wrong but
my understanding and the way that i've
been able to
finally find some compassion for myself
and parts of myself is to recognize that
the things that we view
in ourselves is totally [ __ ] up
totally self-destructive
totally fill in the blank pejorative
term very often are not maladaptive they
are perfectly adaptive they've just
outlived their usefulness or they've
they've kind of expired but they still
remain if that makes any sense and so
the
the non-pathologizing and any piece of
what i just said i'd love to hear you
respond to well you said it really well
um and that it's been a tough sell in
my field but that is what i found back
with that client and subsequently with
thousands of clients
not just myself but all the people using
this around the world
are finding that these things we thought
were
symptoms are maladaptive in the sense
that in our current context they may not
be needed but
they were definitely needed they were
like heroes like i was saying
back when we were being hurt and they
get
stuck back there so again i'm a family
therapist so i'm
trying to understand the context of all
kinds of
both external people's behavior and
internal
and the internal parts behavior made
total sense
back when you were being hurt and they
think they still need to do it because
they think you're still
in the same kind of vulnerability so
yeah so it has been a tough sell
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs the new year is here
and it marks a fresh start for your
small business whether you're shifting
business hours or hiring more remote
employees
one thing that remains unchanged is the
importance of having the right people on
your team
when your business is ready to make that
next hire linkedin jobs can help by
matching your role with qualified
candidates so you can find
the right person quickly and to lend a
helping hand
your first job post is free getting
started is easier than ever with new
features to help you find qualified
candidates quickly
from linkedin's active community of
professionals with more than 722 million
members
worldwide post a job with targeted
screening questions
to get your role in front of more
qualified candidates you can manage
job posts and contact candidates on the
familiar linkedin.com website
where functions are streamlined into one
simple screen
and now you can do all this from your
mobile device no matter where the day
takes you
when your business is ready to make that
next hire find the right person with
linkedin jobs and now you can post a job
for
free just visit linkedin.com slash tim
again that's linkedin
dot com slash tim to post a job for free
terms and conditions do apply
i would say that you know many
of the most important
and impactful inputs that i've had in
the last handful of years
from a healing perspective and
furthermore not just from a healing
perspective getting back to whole but
even just becoming a hopefully i know
this is a really generic term like
better human so not just getting to
baseline but actually going beyond
baseline in some ways
has related to self-compassion and
radical acceptance by tara brock would
be a very in some respects buddhist
mindfulness approach to that
and i feel like ifs is a very
tactical practical framework
for actually kind of getting after it
almost in a tennis match type of way i
mean not not that it's adversarial but
with the assistance of someone else and
i'd love to explore what some of these
parts are
and to explore for instance
protectors and some of these other
labels just to
give people an understanding of what
this looks like in practice what do you
think the best way to do that
is is it giving a conceptual overview of
some type
is it just getting into it and you and i
rolling up the sleeves and
seeing what happens if i gave a brief
conceptual overview then
what we tend what we do with each other
would make more sense to people
so let me great let me do that so
as i was exploring this with clients
back in the day i'm a systems person i'm
looking for distinctions and patterns
and
the big distinction that leaped out
immediately as i was doing it with more
and more clients
was between parts that were very
young in the culture has been called
these these wonderful
inner children who were vulnerable
and sensitive and often were the parts
of us
that are the most hurt by the traumas
they take it the most personally
and they get the most frightened and the
feel the most worthless often
and once those young
formerly happy-go-lucky delightful
creative inner parts of us
once they get hurt that way they have
the power
to overwhelm us and give us all the
burdened emotions that they carry so
not knowing we're locking up our most
juicy parts we tend to try and get away
from them and put them in inner
basements or
abysses or caves so i call them the
exiles
and we've all done that one degree or
another even if you haven't had a lot of
trauma
there are ways our culture or your
family
didn't accept certain parts of you and
so you had to
move away from them and we do it not
realizing
we think we're just moving away from
dreadful memories or sensations
or emotions but we are locking up these
parts of us
that are so wonderful and have so many
talents when they're not
locked up and when they're not stuck in
the past
so when you have a lot of exiles then
the world becomes a lot more
dangerous and you feel a lot more
delicate
so other parts have to jump into other
protective roles
some of which are designed to control
the world so
your exiles don't get triggered because
if they get triggered then it's like
flames of emotion
threaten to consume you and these
protectors often think you're going to
die
if you stay with that so there are parts
that'll keep you a certain distance from
people
there are parts that will control your
appearance so you don't get rejected
parts that try to make you your
performance perfect
so you get a lot of accolades to counter
the worthlessness
so all that we call protect those are
manager protectors because they're
managing
a lot they're trying to they're like
what in family therapy we used to call
parentified inner children in a family
where the parents advocate
the kids have to become the parents they
were called parental
parental children this happens inside of
us too these younger
parts have to kind of run our lives
and they get extreme because they
they're in over their heads
often they become these critics they're
yelling at us just to try and get us to
behave
they don't know what else to do than to
yell at us and
so those are some of the common
manager roles others are these massive
caretaking parts that
don't let us take care of ourselves only
take care of everybody else
there's just a lot of common manager
roles
when that doesn't work and the world
breaks through those quote-unquote
defenses
and triggers our exiles it's a big
emergency and
so there's another set of parts who's on
call almost
who immediately goes into action to take
us out to
get us higher than the flames of emotion
or to douse them with some substance or
to distract
us until they burn themselves out so
those we call
firefighters because they're fighting
the fire of this exiled emotion inside
of you
and and we all have some of those and
most of us have a kind of hierarchy of
them
if the first one doesn't work we go to
the next one if that doesn't work
the next one and the top of the
hierarchy is often suicide
it's a big kind of comfort to many
people to know if things get bad enough
there's always that safety net i can
exit strategy
but other kinds of firefighter
activities include a lot of addictions
and and for me it's it sounds like for
you too it's
work is one of mine firefighter
activities
eating was one of mine it's not anymore
so
you know those are some of the common
firefighters so
most all of us walk around with some
version of that system
the more trauma you experienced the more
exiles you have than the more extreme
your parts often are
in addition to all of that though and
this is actually the big
discovery in ifs as i was doing this
work and i would
as a family therapist try to have
dialogues inside
among these different parts like i was
within a family
often i'd have to get one part to
kind of separate or move back or step
out for a second
so i could have two others talk to each
other because the other was interfering
and as i started doing that process of
getting parts to
open more space inside and not you know
be chattering all the time
slowed it down it was like another
person would pop out
who took the lead and uh was
just immediately curious about these
parts or even had
a lot of compassion suddenly out of the
blue
and also had was calm and
was confident and so
and the parts would relate well to this
person
and when i asked what part of you is
that clients would say some version of
that's not a part like these others
that's myself
so i came to call that the self with a
capital s
and it turns out and this is really
totally amazing
but given all the 40 years we've been
doing this and the thousands of people
doing it around the world
i can safely say that that self capital
s
is in everybody can't be damaged and
knows how to heal
and can be accessed simply by getting
these parts to open space
because it seems it's just beneath the
surface of them
so when i'm working with somebody i will
wait until i hear some of those c words
in addition to the four i mentioned
there's also courage clarity
creativity and connectedness
so i'm waiting to hear when my client
is in that that place before i have them
work with their parts and when when they
work with their parts from that place
they just naturally know how to heal so
if
i may just reflect on what you said for
a second
i mean this is for people who have never
had a psychedelic experience if we look
at the etymology of psychedelic i mean
it is mind
manifesting in us in a sense if we want
to roughly translate it to english
and it's incredible how much
your description of
working with ifs parts and then this
self right this
this sort of a central observer
who has as maybe as stan groff would put
it you know that an innate healing
intelligence or something like that
how much it mirrors what some people can
only achieve
with drugs meaning psychedelic drugs
or plants or fungi of some type right
it's
it's pretty remarkable that you're able
to
sort of engineer and back into
without any type of pharmaceutical
intervention
something very it's very similar and get
to a very similar place
let me comment on that for a second so
yeah
because you mentioned michael and annie
midhoffer and
in phase one when michael was using mdma
with these
mostly combat vets but uh ptsd
clients and he started talking excitedly
about this because
they're both well-trained ifs therapists
i started to feel more and more
validated because
for some reason the mdma seems to get
all your protectors to relax
and so you just by virtue of having
taken the medicine your
in self with those c words that i
described earlier
right and he found and he kept track of
this
he he tracked that phase one group
and he found that over 70 percent
spontaneously started doing ifs without
any coaching from
from him because in the protocol this
they set it up where they couldn't
lead the client it was all kind of you
know following
yeah non-directional right exactly so
that confirmed to me
that i had just stumbled onto a process
that people naturally know how to do
when they access enough self
and they'll do it on their own and
that's true too
it's become a kind of life practice
where people
do this on a daily basis often so how
can we demonstrate this for folks
uh and i'm not gonna lie i'm a little
nervous about
so opening the kimono on the podcast
but uh it seems to be sitting i seem to
be setting a
a trend in doing that with recent
episodes so i might as well just
you know go for it and for a penny and
for a pound so what's
what's a good way to for you and i to
have a chat to try to illustrate some of
these things
uh well if there is a part of you you'd
like to get to know better or
or change your relationship with or
if there's something still getting in
your way from
you mentioned that there was a very
angry part of you
that came up and had all these what
retrospect seemed like minor quibbles
but
we could go there it's it's really up to
you whatever you want to
explore well i i would say
when i've looked at the anger and and
tried to
work with it and it's quite subdued not
exiled or not disavowed but it's it's
not as
as high volume as it used to be even a
few years ago but
i do think that the anger is
very often a byproduct
or a symptom of fear and
so the fear i think could be worth
digging into and something that i've
noticed as i have
successfully contended with
and healed from depression
that anxiety has become more pronounced
and
this sort of vague sense of unease that
something bad can and will happen
that type of anxiety that is that i i
then create narratives around because
i'll say
i'll sort of have this wave of anxiety
and then explain it in all sorts of ways
that
may not be accurate but that has become
something that i've
noticed more and more
as depression has become less and less
of a an ongoing battle for me in the
last
five or six years okay and uh i'd love
to kind of explore
that because i've tried many things
to move from a place of
anxiety and fear to a place of
trust and faith and god damn is it hard
you know maybe i'm just exposed to too
many ugly
aspects of the world where i get to see
really bad behavior and
sort of lord of the flies type dynamics
quite a bit but
that is something i wouldn't mind
digging into
right absolutely yeah yeah
happy to help you with that uh and you
know that trust
in the world is safe is is tough to
get through willpower so we'll try to
we'll try it this other way so are you
ready
i'm just i'm as ready as i'm gonna be
yeah
okay so the way we start is have you
focus on that anxiety and find it in
your body or around your body
okay and as you notice it there
where do you find it by the way uh right
now as i'm thinking about it i feel in
the throat
and that's quite common like a
constriction in the throat
okay uh i also will feel it
basically right over the heart like a
constriction on the left side of my
chest
okay but right now i'm feeling it mostly
in the throat all right so let's start
there
so as you notice it there in your throat
tell me how you feel toward that part of
you
that's so anxious
well if i'm being honest i suppose i
want it to go away i wanted to
let go so that i can feel more
certainly less constriction physically
right in the throat it's not pleasant it
doesn't feel
good to me right i
i would say there's anger towards that
fearful part also because objectively
i can look at my life and my
surroundings and
everything's [ __ ] great i mean like
you know it's so i get i
i get very upset at that part
which i can understand it does get in
your way and
and uh but we're going to ask the one
who's angry at it
and the one who wants it to go away both
of those parts we're going to ask
to give us a little space to get to know
it just for a few minutes
and actually maybe try to help it in a
different way
rather than trying to make it go away so
just see if those parts would be willing
to relax in there
so you could open your open your mind to
it a little bit
so the just for clarity the angry part
and the
anxious part fearful part i'm asking
both of those to kind of
stand down for a few minutes no no no no
we want the
anxious part to stick around we want
the one who doesn't like the angry
anxious part to step back
and the one who wants to get rid of it
so
just see if you can open your mind to
the anxious one
all right so how do you feel toward it
now
i feel more empathetic
yeah i mean it just seems like a scared
child where
there you go so let it know you have
some empathy for it
and you care about it you want to get to
know it better
and just ask what it wants you to know
and don't think of the answer tim just
wait for something to come from that
from your throat yeah it already came as
soon as you
prompted it was i don't know what to do
yeah that was
that was the that's what came to mind
and how do you feel toward it now as you
get how
sort of confused it feels
yeah i feel a lot of compassion for it
so let it know
let it know you get it's it's confused
and scared
and just see there's more it wants you
to get about it's
that that feeling of i don't know what
to do
just see if there's more that comes yeah
i don't want to mess things up
like i'm like i'm not trying to mess
things up
something along those lines yeah
okay and
let it know you you just want to keep
getting to know it why does it
worry so much about messing things up
whatever it wants you to know about all
that
well it seems like uh
i just seems like kind of a confused
scared
child there and i guess what it's trying
to communicate is that
it's not intentionally trying to
mess up my life
it is just unsure of
how to sort of quell that
that's great fear
and do you see this child in there or
you just sense him
i yeah it's you know it's
this is kind of a
uh you know an unusual practice and
visualize it so i'm highly visual so for
me right now as i'm talking to you i'm
looking out the window
and i kind of feel at least i've been
envisioning this part this scared part
to my left like the kind of left
peripheral
visual field and
for whatever reason it's not a child
like in my mind it's actually
like an adult version of myself that
just has the
uh the fear and the wide-eyed look
and the uh
scattered nature of a fearful child
okay and as you
see him there from in your periphery how
close would you say you are to him in
terms of feet away
like eight to ten feet okay
and is it possible to get closer to him
and turn more toward him
yep it's possible so how close can you
get now
well since i'm sitting in front of a mic
i'm kind of inviting him over
otherwise it's going to make this
podcast very difficult so
so i invited him to have a seat at the
table so we are about
uh four four and a half feet away now
we're we're sitting more or less
directly across the table from each
other
okay and and once again just
let him know that
these you get these other parts have
been very hard on him
but they're not around right now and
that you actually care about him
and just see how he reacts
yeah seems to be sort of softening and
relaxing
okay yeah
okay and just again ask if there's
anything more he wants to know about
his anxiety and confusion
there's nothing nothing coming to mind
immediately he's just
sort of sitting more relaxed good
at the table ask him this question then
does he protect other parts of you
um
uh you know i mean it's i guess i was
gonna say
i don't know if i'm making this up or
not but i guess one could make the
argument that i'm
you know one can make the argument i'm
making none of it up or making all of it
up but so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna give the commentary but
uh the other part of me that was abused
like the part of me that
they that was
sort of constantly
at risk of some unpredictable
abuse as a little kid uh and i mean it
wasn't limited to the
two to four uh sort of sexual abuse
there was there was a lot of other i was
bullied really really
severely up until about sixth grade it's
very very small kid
so it's there's a lot of
unpredictability
in my life uh just kind of start to
finish
as a kid so protecting
uh that part of me that was always kind
of waiting for the other shoe to drop
okay so this is a kind of
choice point for you tim because i'm
happy to go
to that one but that would be
more vulnerable and more exposing so uh
it's it's your call and i don't you know
i don't want
you to feel any pressure to do it well
uh
i mean i don't want to get into
specifics of like the sexual abuse or
anything like that no
you won't have to disclose anything
about what you see
yeah okay well let's let's try it let's
give let's give it a go
well before we do just check around
inside and see if there is any fear
about doing it
i want to be sure we're doing with full
permission
i mean there's a little bit of
trepidation but i know i can always cut
right i i'm the master of the audio
so i feel i feel okay with uh with that
since we're not we're not live casting
this
all right so then go ahead and focus on
that abused
part of you and find him find him in
your body around your body
hmm okay where do you find them
you know i'm also i'm still feeling
i mean the dominant uh
constriction is in the throat and
you know i also find myself wondering if
this
frightened part of me
is one and the same with the abused but
i i don't wanna
well you couldn't start now you'll get
the answer if you just ask
ask if that's the case and just wait for
the answer
yeah i think it is the same i think that
is the same
all right and and you're still
across the table from him yep still
across the table
and ask if he trusts now that you care
about him
yeah he does all right
then if he's up for it and ready then
tell him to show you and let you feel
and sense and see whatever he needs you
to
about how bad it all was and again don't
think tim
just wait and see what comes to you and
you don't have to disclose any of it
but you can disclose what feels okay
yeah it's just it's just a horrible
stream of
images and scenes of
like abuse and violence and
a fearful little kid who was just
constantly hyper vigilant because of
that
and are you okay watching all that
i mean i don't enjoy watching it but i
can
i feel like i can handle it yeah so let
him know
you're okay so far that you really you
really want to get how bad it was for
him
as much as he wants you to so okay
just tell him you're ready
just see if there's more
yeah there's more um nothing
shockingly new but just painting a
fuller picture of
a pretty scared pretty sad
childhood for a lot of the time
not always but for a lot of the time
yeah so it's really good
that you're getting how bad it was
and getting more of the either the
details or the emotions
and just tell him to keep going if he
needs to
i'm gonna stay with him until he feels
like you really get it now
yeah i feel that petering out a bit i
mean i got a lot
so i i feel like i've received what
has been sent but just ask him directly
and see if he's
see if he agrees this is what he wanted
you to get
yeah it would be ourselves okay
all right tom so now i want you to
go to that boy in that time period
some point in that time period and be
with him in the way he needed somebody
and just tell me when you're in there
with them
yep i'm there and how are you being with
him
oh well he's actually sitting in a chair
[Music]
another chair it's like the board of
directors here i was sitting at a
sitting in another chair uh
yeah just a few feet across from me okay
and but but you're in that time period
with him is that true
i i can be yeah if you want me to sort
of transport myself back to that time
period i can do that too
that that is what i want yes okay got it
tell me when you're back there with him
okay i'm there and how are you being
with him
back there i'm sitting on the floor he's
playing with
uh blocks on the floor and i'm just
sitting there being with him in the
living room and how is it for him to
have you there
can you tell i think it's
comforting to have sort of a
non-threatening
i suppose in some ways protective male
yeah uh there
so he does seem to acknowledge you're
there and feels comforted
yeah feels yeah comfortable
all right then ask him what he wants you
to do for him back there
before we take him out to a good place
there's something he wants you to do
some some person he wants you to deal
with whatever he wants
yeah this is where we get into territory
that might not make it onto the live
version here
um hmm
i mean he would like me to say a few
things to some some people
i would say for sure i don't know if
i'll get into the specifics
uh but i can think about the specifics
certainly
yeah you don't have to disclose what you
say it's just for you to do for him
so while he while he watches go ahead
and say those things to those people
okay done and ask him what that was like
for him to watch you do that
for him
oh well you know he
he has a
sort of my hero type look on his face
that's great right to have somebody
stand up for him
in that way that's right so tell him
you're going to be doing that for him
from now on
and see if he'd like to leave that time
and place with you
and come to a safe comfortable place
now
okay yes okay so
take him wherever he'd like to go it
could be the president could be a
fantasy place with a read like
all right where do you have them
took him to this
farm property that i own lots of trails
and woods
and room to room to play in rome
beautiful all right and tell him he can
stay there he never has to go back
to that time and you're going to take
care of him
and given that ask him if you'd like to
unload the feelings and beliefs
he got back there from those times
uh answer is yes and ask him where he
carries all that in his body or on his
body
first thing that came to mind i don't
know why is the
traps like the trapezius
kind of between the neck and the
shoulders yeah yeah
and ask what he'd like to give it all up
to light
water fire wind earth anything else
what he would like to give it up to like
an elephant yeah
it doesn't have to be it could be
anything else
um i think i think i
could you give me again some examples
just because i'm not sure how to answer
that yeah so light
or water or fire
wind earth anything else
just check with him let's let's have him
pick
okay revision fire fire
all right tim so set up a fire for him
and tell him to take all that out of the
place in his body
and to let the fire take care of it just
put it in the fire
until it's all gone
done good how does he feel now without
it
looks a lot happier looks ready ready to
jump up and down
that's great and before he does that
just if he wants to he can invite into
his body
qualities that he'd like to have and you
can just see what comes into him now
yeah confidence
that's the first one okay yeah that
might be
all he wants so he seems good
seems good yeah all right so let's bring
in this
original guy the anxious adult guy
yep have him see how this boy is doing
now and just see how he reacts
yeah just deep deep exhales kind of
sighing
exhales of relaxation that's great
and you can see if there's anything he'd
like to put in the fire too
just ask him
yeah okay so he did
yeah let me just make sure that i
envision that really clearly give me one
more second
sure
yep done just just to to add some color
for people who are listening along i
mean hopefully people can listen to this
and kind of take themselves through it
as well
uh possibly but it's so [ __ ] bizarre
how these things sometimes work i mean
and it's
also kind of magical and in a sense i
mean because
he's he took fear out of his abdomen and
put it into the fire but
was not you premeditated i don't know
where that came from
so no but who cares who cares yeah i
mean i mean it's that's
good enough what you're getting is that
this is a real other world
it's not like you imagine it so yeah
so okay how does he seem now
yeah much much more at ease good
and uh yeah
uh does that feel complete for now
yeah i think so i think so and i'd love
if you mean by complete we can
we we would then do sort of a post-game
analysis and you can
sure add add on to that yes that feels
complete for now so we can uh
yeah so focus back outside
and before we stop just notice your
throat and see how it feels now
yes that's it's like if it was at an
eight volume before it's at
like a two two or less volume now that's
great
okay yeah we can do our post game
so maybe let's start with you and what
it was like
i mean this is i'm gonna sound like a
one trick pony here so you have to
forgive me and i'll beg forgiveness from
my audience also but it feels very
psychedelic i mean it really
it is very reminiscent of the
non-pathological splitting
of the psyche or maybe it's just the
recognizing of separate
parts of the psyche better put right
that uh i mean it puts you in a very
non-ordinary state or at least
that was my experience very much yeah
and it's the same state that shamans
take people into
it's it's a real other a real other
world
and uh i stumbled onto this way of
accessing it
and operating it and and uh
you know in terms of my post game um
we could do all that because you had
access
very quickly to a lot of self for the
capital s
and i engaged that i gave that by
when i asked you initially how you felt
with the guy in your throat
and you said you didn't like them and
you wanted to get rid of them
and then i had those parts step back and
i asked now how do you feel toward them
immediately you had empathy you remember
that yeah i do
and so that's what we find over and over
when these other parts step back you
enter that
empathic compassionate leader place
and once we got you in that place
i knew we would be able to do a lot
because
you just started to do it i i led you to
some degree but
you your parts responded really well to
you as
this leader that they didn't really know
that well
and so yeah then we could get to know
the anxious man and
so he turned out to be a manager in that
classification i gave earlier
he was trying to keep you from taking
risks probably and
sort of manage your life through anxiety
and and then there was a point where i
had you ask him if he protected somebody
else
remember that they do and then he
lets you know he protected this exiled
boy
who was still stuck back in those
traumas those
scenes of abuse and bullying
and so the way we heal those parts
is what you did which was to become a
compassionate witness
to the boy so he feels like finally you
really get everything about how bad it
was
and then to actually go to him in that
time period
and do a redo in the sense of being with
him and and
talking to the people he he needed you
to talk to
and and for him you know people say you
can't change the past
for these parts in this inner world that
literally changes their experience of
what happened
and and so then we could take him out to
a safe place
on your farm and at which point these
exiles
generally if they trust they can stay
there and you're going to take care of
them
are willing to give up the emotions and
beliefs they've been carrying
even though i don't know how old you are
but it
sounds like it's maybe been 30 years or
so
yeah it's been been a long time yeah i'm
40 43 i forget how old i am
that's my sign i'm getting older right
well wait till you're my age yeah so
yeah so that's that's what we did and
then once once we unburdened is my
language for letting all that go
he gave up the fire and we bring in the
qualities of
confidence then we have the protector
come in and see
he doesn't have to protect this boy
anymore and he
as you can see felt much more relaxed
and we could help him on burden too
so that was actually quite a piece of
work and again
the reason we could do so much is
because you had so much access
to self pretty quickly for many other
people it takes a long time
to get those other parts to step back
and not interfere
yeah parts work is just
it's it i you would you would think that
at this point in my life having been
exposed to
parts work in different ways
in different very different contexts
also
in some cases enhanced and in some cases
not
that it would just be another day at the
office but i am
always when i experience it firsthand so
impressed
by how powerful parts work
is and can be and i would love to hear
you speak
to how this applies to people who might
suffer from
suicidal ideation and
i'm referring to another editorial piece
and there's a quote here that i'm going
to read
from one such patient or client who had
suicidal ideation and here's the quote
for me the most amazing thing was
learning about about a part of me that
was suicidal and knowing that
that was just a single part of me it
wasn't my entire being that changed my
world
i try to share that with a lot of people
because i know a lot of people who get
very depressed and sometimes feel
suicidal
if you can step back from that feeling
and realize that it's just a part of you
that's trying to take away your pain and
suffering
then you can move through it and find a
different way to deal with it to help
that
part could you expand on this
or speak to it give examples however
whatever makes sense in terms of
fleshing this out because speaking of
someone who's
came very close to taking his own life
this is a very very a very big
lens swap for someone who is suicidal or
suffering from suicidal ideation so it
really does help
to know that all these things aren't you
they're parts of you that often are just
trying to protect
so for me there aren't alcoholics there
aren't you know i'm against all these
monolithic labels
because yes you've got a part that tries
to protect you by getting you drunk all
the time
but it's just a part of you and it's one
of your firefighters
and then most people don't realize that
if they took away your drinking
suicide is the next one on the list the
next one on the ladder
and that would be jumping in if not for
the drinking so then you gotta
honor the drinking part for keeping you
alive and i'll go to suicide so
i've worked many many years with highly
suicidal clients
and they as you can imagine as you
probably were were terrified of
of that part of them and like you said
they were so blended with it
they didn't even they thought it was who
they were so yes
that first step of seeing it is just
apart
like you just did with the anxiety
not only that but if you begin to get to
know it
i can tell you the common dialogue we
have so
i would say to you tim ask that part why
it wants to kill you or what's it afraid
would happen if it didn't kill you
do you want to uh give a spontaneous
answer to that
oh i wasn't i i didn't have my uh my
shoes on ready to with for the starting
gun could you say that one more time and
then
it's okay i'll give you the common
answers so
i i would have you asked the part why it
wants to kill you what's afraid what
happened if it didn't kill you
generally the first thing that comes to
mind is i just want it to stop
like there's a loop that i can't turn
off it's just a thought loop
of hatred or self-loathing or whatever
it might be
and then there's another part that knows
life is pretty good and it's like well
[ __ ] if this is never going to stop
what's the [ __ ] point i just want it
to stop
that's that would be that that's right
and so if we were doing the work
i would say ask this part if we could
get that loop to just to stop
in a different way without having to
kill you would it still want to kill you
and most of these parts say no no yeah
but it would be no yeah it would be no
but i don't think you can do that or i
wouldn't try to kill him
right yep and i'd say if you give me a
chance i can prove that we can
i guarantee it so i'm what i call a hope
merchant
i'm selling hope to hopeless systems
and you know i wouldn't do it if i
didn't know we could follow through and
actually
stop that loop so
that's generally how we work with
suicide and
uh and once these suicidal parts trust
that there is this alternative they know
they're going down with the ship they
don't want to die
so if there is an alternative they'll go
for it
and do you stop the loop just
just to not leave that cliffhanger of a
of a of a promise if if you say that to
a client who's suffering from suicidal
ideation is the
delivery mechanism doing what we just
did in some fashion
getting them to the point where they are
speaking from the place of the self
where they can
excuse and reinvite different parts
including the part with the loop is that
how
you shepherd them to that yeah
yeah it's accessing self and then
finding the parts that are creating the
loop
and then doing what we did with your
parts you know a different version of it
because they would be different parts
and and then and then just like as you
found they this one doesn't have to keep
you so anxious now
they wouldn't have to keep doing that
loop and then
the suicidal part would see that and
would say okay i guess i
i was wrong you could pull this off
so yeah be like that there are
circumstances
where the external world is so
dreadful for somebody that you can't
just do this inside you have to actually
i'm still a family therapist so i'm
going to still do what i can to change
that external context
too so i didn't want to be facile and
say all you got to do is this
feeling inside and everything will be
fine
yeah sometimes you got to take the rock
out of your shoe and not just change how
you relate to the rock
right i mean that's right
the quote i was going to read is from
carl rogers and
i know you are familiar with this quote
and
it is quote the curious paradox is that
when i accept myself just as i am
then i can change end quote
is there anything you would like to like
to say
after my mention of that is there well
that you know that's sort of the
foundation of this work is not just
accepting you know you could get to a
place of acceptance of that anxiety guy
and that would help him not feel beat up
by those other parts
you with me so far yes
but that wouldn't necessarily help him
on burden
you know what i'm saying he wouldn't
necessarily help him actually transform
so this is a step beyond what a lot of
maybe spiritual traditions do which
would be to get you mindfully
accepting of your parts radical
acceptance you know that
it's all a great it's a great first step
but then rather than having yourself be
a passive witness
accepting witness you became with your
parts an
active inner parent an active leader an
active i'm going to help you
so that that's one of the big
differences with ifs
let me return to psychedelics for a
moment in the psychedelic experience
it's perhaps a it's not i wouldn't say
it's a common misconception because i do
try to be the
voice of restraint and caution
as often as possible but just for the
sake of
making the point i want to make i'll say
it could be a misconception that i want
or
think all people should have psychedelic
experiences with
strong compounds whether it be you know
psilocybin lsd
mescaline ayahuasca or otherwise and
that's just patently not true because
it's not
suitable for all people in all
circumstances it just simply is not
and there are risks involved so i'm
fascinated by
the prospect i mean it sounds like for
you a reality that
this is an alternate or complementary
way of accessing
in some respects the same space
and the same workspace the have you also
found or heard anecdotally that ifs
or working with ifs has helped prepare
people to be
more adept or hesitate to use the word
productive
but to be more prepared for psychedelic
experiences with
compounds yes and we're doing
ultimately we're going to do some
training but uh
you know i like michael and annie's
training
but i think it could be there could be
more rfs in there
to to use more rfs in those prep
sessions
and then after in the after
math uh to actually help people
understand
what they they experienced and to
follow up to help them keep going so
yeah i'm hoping i've been working at it
that ifs can be kind of the map to that
territory in general
and so that uh yes
in addition to the prep sessions where
you would first check the parts that
might be scared to do it
or you know the kinds of parts that
might come
up during the time and just help the
person
get to know those a little bit in
advance and get permission to do the
psychedelic experience and then
during it as these parts come up even
scary ones
you know there is such a thing as post
psychedelic
trauma uh syndrome where
yeah where people we speak to that this
is important
people do have really bad experiences
i've worked with people who
were severely traumatized and you know
and it's set
in motion a kind of psychotic process so
these are delicate ecologies we're
entering
and we need a very ecologically
sensitive map
and so if that were to happen
either during the psychedelic experience
or as a kind of backlash
afterwards for the the guide to know
what that is and not
panic themselves and to be able to
to work with the part that that is come
out in a soothing way which
also involves the self
energy of the guide so that harvest can
also be used to help
uh the sitters work with themselves and
get their parts to open space for their
self to be
very present which really makes a huge
difference in the experience of the
person doing it yeah
absolutely and to just
reiterate something you said i mean
they're the stories
that are most commonly shared related to
psychedelics
are suffer from a survivorship bias
right so uh in the sense that
just like if you pick up barons or one
of these investment magazines or
newspapers the only mutual funds that
are still
advertising are the ones that survived
and it can create a very
distorted picture of just how
safe these things might be and that's
true also
with drugs where like the people who
died of heroin overdoses aren't
available for interviews so
you don't get to hear from them
psychedelics of generally speaking
physiologically not being
any anywhere close at least if we're
talking about the classic psychedelics
like
lsd or psilocybin physiologically their
ld50 is going to be
nowhere close to something like an
opiate but
the point being that if you are a
clinician as you are
you get to see the whole spectrum of
post psychedelic experiences
and that includes people who have
psychotic breaks or people who suffer
from
what some scientist friends of mine have
called ontological shock
where they just they they aren't
completely unraveled but they
really don't know what is real anymore
or who they are right or who they are
and you also have people
i'm a case study in this who go into an
experience
thinking they have no trauma or a
certain level
of lower case t trauma and then
under the influence of these compounds
have the opening of the floodgates where
they
suddenly realize that there's a lot more
in pandora's box
and once that is uncorked and they
return to ordinary reality don't know
how to metabolize that or work with it
or contend with it which
can lead to all sorts of problems and
i just want to make it really clear that
these are these are very powerful
experiences that
i think require the same type of due
diligence and forethought as
going into neurosurgery or yeah
uh or process or a process like that and
you wouldn't look for your neurosurgeon
on craigslist
or encourage them to buy their tools
through the dark web so
you know similarly how can one
make if they can ifs
or or this type of work a daily practice
is it a daily practice
or is it something that you just
go for the gusto with every once in a
while and a really intense therapeutic
session
how do you think about how do you think
about that
yeah one of the things i like about it
most
is that it it easily translates into a
daily practice so
as i thought about as i thought about
this interview and also we had
the listeners don't know but we had some
technical snafus in the beginning and i
i could feel my panic parts coming up
and
and uh you know i knew you were waiting
and
and so inside i'm
saying i get it i get you you're scared
this isn't going to happen
but just trust me just relax just step
back i can handle this
remember it always goes better when i
when i'm in the lead just let me handle
this
and during that even that time when they
were so panicked
i would just feel this parting of the
seas
and and myself would come back i'd have
access to it again and
my confidence is back and my all those c
words and so i do that on a daily basis
if i'm going to face something scary
i'll do a little
prep session with my parts a little pep
talk
about okay i know you guys this will be
triggering but
just let me handle it and then
if they get triggered during a session
or during a
time during the week and i can't
un-blend i can't separate from them then
i bookmark that and i call my therapist
and i do a piece of work around it like
the piece of work we just did and
so then i do a lot of unburdening in the
session but then i follow up after the
session
so my homework for you is to check on
that boy
and that that adult part of you every
day for about a month
and just make sure they're still doing
okay and treat it you know very
seriously like
it's not your imagination it's actually
real
even if you don't believe it treat it
that way and this will stick
yeah so when i'm working with clients
and
we've done a lot of work and at the end
they'll say some version of
you're a pretty good therapist but i
healed myself and that's
really what we're shooting for
i like that uh how do you suggest
people build in this chicken i would
imagine this is common homework
where they are checking in on these
parts when do they do it
how long do they do it for when they
first get up when they're eating
breakfast
what does a check-in or what might a
good check-in look like
yeah it just it's very variable
different
clients do it differently there are some
who will do
a sit for an hour every day and just
really keep it going and
they actually get to where they can do
on burnings on their own and
the first 20 minutes of our session
they're just telling me all this stuff
they did
at home and then i okay let's go in and
do some more
and then there are people who are more
like me who you know i'll remember
especially if i write it down a part
that i've been working with and needs my
attention
and like i said when i get up in the
morning i'll just lay in bed and
check on it and see how it is and but i
can't do a whole lot more than that for
some reason i've got
parts that interfere on my own so
i do a lot of the big healing work with
somebody else and then
i do the maintenance work on my own
every day
so it it just varies from person to
prison
but i can do that notice the parts
getting triggered
and not think it's me know it's a part
and separate from it in the moment
is the process we've been talking about
a lot
let's talk about adding in some some
additional variables
uh so you have said that often when
couples are fighting they're in a
protector war
if i'm getting the reference right
can you expand on that what does that
mean what is it yeah what does it mean
and then
how do you how might you approach
resolving it
if if there are couples listening who
are in quarantine who might not have
access to a therapist
yeah so often i give my wife and i as an
example but she got tired of me doing
that so i'm not gonna
yeah yeah
well like that's understand
understandable yeah so
when i'm working with couples most of
the time it is these
protectors who have taken over each of
them and are doing the talking
so it's maybe the man's
angry part i don't want to be gendered
about this
it's one partner's angry part yeah it's
okay
i mean you could give the hypothetical
heteronormative
just to make it easy uh for just
the example of course people chill out
this can apply to any couple but let's
let's just
yeah let's just go with all right so in
this case we have a man and a woman
the man has the angry part yeah
so he's really angry about something his
wife said
and she's in this big defensive part
and is just trying to justify it and
and so on and it's just these two parts
interacting
in a nasty way a lot of the time and
unbeknownst to each of them or maybe
even known to each of them
those protectors are triggering the
exiles of the other person
each time they say something they're
hurting these
these wounded children inside and the
more
those exiles get hurt then the more the
extreme the protectors become
and that's the loop that most couples
are in
there's a i believe it's an indian
saying that goes something like
when the water buffalo battle in the
marsh is the frogs who suffer
so when these protectors go to war
both parties often don't even know the
damage they're doing to the other person
at all because all they see is the
protective part
but that damage really can erode the
relationship ultimately
so when we're working with such a couple
the first move is to do what we call a
u-turn in their focus
that means get each of them to stop
focus inside
noticing the parts that are doing the
talking
get to know them a little bit come back
out when they can speak for them rather
than from them
so if you and i got into it tim i might
say
so tim it it really really i just can't
stand that you just said that
so that would be a protector speaking
speaking period and if
our therapist said okay dick just
go inside listen to that angry part it
just spoke
listen to what it protects and come back
when you can speak
from this open-hearted place for both of
those parts
and i might say some version of okay i
did that
and i noticed this angry one and it
really wanted me to ream you out
and then i asked what it was protecting
and it was this this boy
who would hear something very similar
from my
father when he would yell at me and this
angry guy said i'm never going to let
that happen again
no one can talk to me like that and so
that's what was happening for me when i
was saying that to you
so you see the difference i do
and once you've had let's just say both
people in the couple right so in our
previous
example like the man and the woman they
they do the u-turn
they're both able to come back does that
is is like a problem have to find half
solved in this case is are you kind of
halfway there or
or is there a next step once each person
can say
this part was protecting this part and
i'm able to
kind of speak from this calmer observer
self about these two now and you get the
man and the woman back in the room
what happens from that point forward
yeah there are several next steps
so one side of ifs is having them
interact with each other from self
speaking for their parts sort of in the
way i just described but
my job then becomes simply being the
parts detector
so as they talk to each other i'll say
time out
you're talking from these parts i want
you both to go inside
come back when you can be more and self
when you speak
and then when they can and they stay in
self just hold them in that space
as they talk about their issues and what
i find is just that
just being able to have a self to self
conversation with somebody
you do start to heal on your own
basically just like self
can do that in the inner world itself
can do that in the outer world
now as we do that there may be parts
that aren't willing to
step back and you know that are still
quite burdened and so
the other thing i'll do is i would do a
piece of work with you
while your partner witnessed that work
so if
let's say that anxious part was really
getting in the way in your
relationship and your partner watched me
do that
and saw the back story to why this
part's so anxious
what's your partner going to feel
empathy empathy yeah so rather than
being critical of you for being so
scared
or whatever it was now they have empathy
for this part of you and they want to
encourage you to keep
working with it and healing it so that's
a major intervention in a relationship
as well
and so i'll have people work with the
parts that are
getting in the way of the relationship
the most while their partner watches so
that's a whole other
side of ifs let's talk to another
example of being a merchant of hope as
you put it
or a hope merchant trailheads
uh i want to talk about trailheads in an
interview i believe was an interview
might have been a blog post
it is an interview on 1440.org
here's the paragraph i want to unpack
quote
if i'm working with a client who is a
former alcoholic and they come in and
tell me sheepishly they went off the
wagon this week i say that's great
because this is a trailhead and if we
follow the trail it will lead us right
to the part we need to heal that we
haven't got to yet
can you please elaborate on
trailheads yeah as you can imagine
that's
a bit of a radical statement in this
field but
that's yes that is my experience that
these whatever extreme belief emotion
sensation
you know you mentioned on your farm
there are a lot of trails
and those trails have trailheads where
you start
and if you start the trailhead and then
follow the trail you'll come to some
lake that's beautiful or something like
that
if we take whatever
like in your case it was this anxiety
that you felt
as the trail head that led us to this
adult part that was protecting the exile
so
any kind of symptom becomes that
becomes a trailhead that'll take us to a
pot of gold really
and uh i mean that that's also
reminiscent to me
in some respects of gabor mate and
ask not why the addiction but why the
pain and
i quote i use that line all the time and
i know
no kidding yeah and he and i are good
friends and uh
like mutual admiration thing yeah
he's a fascinating guy he's he's
independent fascinating for people who
want to
further explore ifs or get to
a better understanding of ifs perhaps
even find
a therapist who is knowledgeable with
ifs
what are some of the resources tools
that you would suggest people start with
and let's assume
for the sake of argument that let's say
simplicity really that these are
are lay people not practitioners not
therapists yeah
so uh our website is ifs hyphen
institute dot com and on it there's a
store
and there are lots of books for the
public i've written
two of them one's called an introduction
to ifas and the others
you're the one you've been waiting for
which is more about relationships
and there are lots of videos and
they're books for kids and there is a
book
called self therapy that was written by
a guy named jay early
that does sort of walk people through
the process
i'm a little anxious about that because
he tells people to go to their exiles on
their own which
i have concerns about but that is also
something some people use successfully i
did a
audio course on sounds true
called greater than the sum of the parts
that
contains a lot of exercises that people
like a lot so i'd recommend that and
there are
more technical books for therapists that
lay people seem to get a lot out of too
sometimes what are those books
well the sort of bible for therapists is
called
oddly enough internal family systems
therapy
second edition which came out just last
year
and there's a a manual
we did for an organization called pessi
that's kind of step by step
and frank anderson is the author of that
for a lay person who really wants to get
of a brass tacks grasp of how they might
use ifs and
their own lives would the
audio course you suggested with the
exercises be
totally a good place to start it can be
overwhelming in a paradox of choice
sense to have
so many books available and not to know
where to start so to get
people to step one if we were to
recommend
that audio course would be a good place
to start very much uh
and those exercises i'm pretty careful
about exiles so
they're they're quite safe i think
yeah great wonderful i will link to that
and everything that we've discussed in
the show notes for people so that will
be available
all in one place at tim dot blog forward
slash podcast
well richard this has been as as hoped
incredibly
fascinating for me i'm glad that we were
also
able to do a a live live demo
of what it looks like in the wild in a
sense is there anything else that you
would like to
share suggest to my audience ask of my
audience
before we wrap up you know just uh
this is a very different paradigm for
understanding human nature
and it changes a lot
if if you really get it and buy into it
and
you know i told the story of in the
early 80s
uh when i finally got that self was in
everybody
i had this vision of possibility like
this could change everything
i hope the guy comes along who can take
it where it's supposed to go because i'm
just a little kid
i'm still waiting for that guy and i'm
still
trying to take it where it's supposed to
go it feels like it's got an energy of
its own
and because it would change a lot to
know that this self is who
everybody really is and that these parts
aren't even what you think they are that
they're
actually very valuable qualities that
who've been distorted by trauma and can
transform this quickly all of that make
a huge difference in
everyday life for most people and also
you know
we're working with high-level
mediators and so on just to try and
bring more peace
it's an incredible paradigm and
set of tools that i will say
was the first framework for talk therapy
that i
saw in living color via video initially
that really really caught my attention
where i was like holy [ __ ] okay these
these before and afters
are really incredible
and it would have been for someone who
hasn't seen
these types of transformations almost
impossible to anticipate that you would
get these outcomes
in such a relatively short period of
time
given the starting points involved and
the levels of trauma
it's really grabbed my attention which
is why i wanted to
have you on the podcast and i appreciate
you very much for taking the time and
making the time
to have a conversation well i'm very
honored and moved actually
by the depth at which you get this and
and for your support and so i've loved
our conversation i really have
having listened to you a lot i kind of
knew i would but
you know i still had these anxious parts
so it's just been
moving is the best word for it for me
well i really appreciate
you and the work that you're doing in
the world hopefully we'll get to meet in
person at some point
in the not too distant post
world and
for everybody listening thank you for
tuning in you can find the show notes
links to everything that we discussed
including the audio course that we
mentioned
towards the end at tim dot blog forward
slash podcast you can just search
ifs and everything will pop right up and
until next time thank you for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off
for the weekend so if you want to
receive that check it out
just go to four hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by athletic greens
i get asked all the time what i would
take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance i recommended it in fact in
the four-hour body this is more than ten
years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole food sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multi vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around right now
athletic greens is giving my audience a
special offer on top of their all-in-one
formula
which is a free vitamin d supplement and
five
free travel packs with your first
subscription purchase many of us
are deficient in vitamin d i found that
true for myself which is usually
produced in our bodies from sun exposure
so
adding a vitamin d supplement to your
daily routine is a great option for
additional immune support support your
immunity
gut health and energy by visiting
athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d
and 5 free travel packs with your
subscription again that's
athleticgreens.com
tim this podcast episode is brought to
you by
helix sleep sleep is super important to
me in the last few years
i've come to conclude it is the end-all
be-all that all good things
good mood good performance good
everything seem to stem
from good sleep so i've tried a lot to
optimize and i've tried
pills and potions all sorts of different
mattresses
you name it and the last few years i've
been sleeping on a helix
midnight luxe mattress i also have one
in the guest bedroom
and feedback from friends has always
been fantastic it's something that they
comment on
helix sleep has a quiz takes about two
minutes to complete that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you
with helix there's a specific mattress
for each and every
body that is your body also your taste
so let's say you sleep on your side
and like a super soft bed no problem or
if you're a back sleeper who likes a
mattress
that's as firm as a rock they've got a
mattress for you too helix was selected
as the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
magazine
wired apartment therapy and many others
just go to helixsleep.com
tim take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk free they'll even pick it up from
you if you don't love it and now my dear
listeners helix is offering up to 200
off of all mattress orders and two free
pillows
at helixsleep.com tim
these are not cheap pillows either so
getting two for free
is an upgraded deal so that's up to 200
off and two free pillows at
helixsleep.com
tim that's helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim for up to two hundred
dollars off
so check it out one more time helix
h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com tim
you